joining me this week is the
commander-in-chief of the Assyrian army
Emmanuel casaba yo Cana commander
how is my pronunciation before we start
you say your name though so it actually
comes off the tongue correctly you want
me to say venecia I want you to say this
I'm 100 shallow you wanna see that has a
nice rhythm to it I gave it an American
ok in the age get crossed up alright
well I'm thrilled that you're here and
I'm honored that you're here because
your people the Assyrian people are
going through something truly horrific
right now and the world seemingly has no
idea so I thought the best place we
could start off is who are the Syrian
people at first Thank You Robin for
having me in your program and the Syrian
people are the indigenous all oldest
people in the Middle East they are
belong to the ancient Assyria Babylon
Nineveh or and they live in that area
and establish and given the human
humanity
the civilization at that time they've
been very creative people and they push
their humanity to to the and they give
them the science the everything kids
belong to the ancient and until now they
well if they find the ark illogical
different things from their science they
are all that they have the only people
they have in their name Sciences geology
and Jesus Christ
talk of their language - so the Syrian
people so our Christian denomination
correct yeah they've been the the first
people became Christian in that area and
they took the Christianity until China
and different people area on countries
yeah and it was once a civilization that
numbered in the millions I think right
and now about how there are a few
hundred thousand Assyrians actually in
Iraq we are a few a few hundred thousand
but in in Iran the world today more than
five six millions people but around the
world
yeah so I always say on the show that
you know in America our news to such a
terrible job about showing really what's
going on in other parts of the world and
helping us understand what other people
are going through we just don't talk
about it especially on cable news so
when you're talking about where the
Assyrians lived so basically in parts of
Iraq is where most of the community is
but then there are some people in in
Syria right and then there's I guess
there's some people in Turkey but the
bulk of it of the the population is in
Iraq yeah before it was mesopotamia yeah
the main state that Assyrian are lived
there and Mr prettiman was a part of
them that from Syria and part from
Turkey and part from Iran before the
border and they the border comes the
state came so the Syrian people are
divided between those countries right
most of them they are in in Iraq right
so the the cause of the Syrian people
has gotten much more dire really in the
last couple years because of Isis but
before we get into that what was it like
living as a ethnic and religious
minority under Saddam Hussein there are
no different between Saddam Hussein or
or the new regime they came for to Iraq
since 2003 Saddam Hussein put a
prosecute in a different way on a Syrian
people now we are facing fanatical
religions thinking that they are put
another pressure on people but they are
no different between Saddam they live
with the same thing the immigration of
flow of our people began when Saddam or
Baath regime became come to rule Iraq
right so before the Saddam regime that
did those were the good old days so to
speak I mean things were okay then right
you you think that it's okay everyone
body but think that Saddam is at that
time was okay to live in Iraq but
actually no Saddam was a dictatorship
and nobody can live in peace with the
dictatorship yeah so flash forward to
what's happening now we're watching
I mean Syria by every estimation isn't
really a sovereign nation anymore it's
it's I don't even know what to call it I
mean it's just we're watching it kind of
crumble so what what's the situation for
the Assyrians right in this very moment
actually Robin we are we are fighting
our last
but to survivor to be in our our
homeland this is what we are doing and
we want to the world to watch and to
reach and to hear our message that they
the Assyrian Christian people need to
help need help to stay in there they
don't want to be immigrated to any other
country let them stay and there in their
land but it's very difficult to say and
in words but this is what we are facing
yeah so the Assyrian people don't
necessarily want to carve out their own
state but want to live peacefully under
whatever state there is whether it's
Iraq or Syria right is the goal
ultimately an Assyrian state not
necessarily from what we were actually
they they want to live and they're in
their land now let's take an example
they've been in every city in Iraq but
since 2003 they've been targeting in
organized targeting they saw they
flitted from every city major city
we have Nineveh plain and that areas
belong to our Assyrian Christian people
so now we are called for for to be at
least a governor or safe having to those
people
but actually the countries or the
decision makers of the countries they
they don't they push us to be part of of
the problem between between KRG or or
Baghdad right they told us in fact you
want to be a part of Iraq so go with
back that or you want to be with KRG so
go with KRG and this is they know that
there are problem between two
two of them and they push us to be a
part of the problem not to be a part of
the solution right so we're talking
about the KRG so that's the Kurdish
regional which is part of Iraq but
basically you're caught between those
two forces right that was the issue
there shows between three big political
forces Arab Sunni yes and Arab Sunni
Arab Shia and Kurdish yeah so when we
were talking before you were telling me
a little bit something that surprised me
which was how much of this really is a
religious problem because I think here
we think that everything it's hard to
tell half the time depending on who
you're talking to everything's either a
religious problem or it's a land problem
but you're saying this really is a
religious problem that in effect the the
Muslim majority does not want Christians
to live there anymore
yeah is that fair to say yeah they don't
want to see a non-muslim robbing the we
lose the Jewish in Iraq in 50s so now we
are losing the Christianity in 2000 and
about so this is the it's belong to the
mentality of the people they are now
they don't think that you are from the
same
country or and you share this country
with with your brother what different is
his religion it's not matter that it's
matter of you are from this country so
this is the situation it's belong to the
mentality and do you see the mentality
of they're all middle-east and before
Isis or after Isis before before Isis
they've been al Qaeda al Qaeda and now
that we are so in each time they came
more fanatic Islam more fanatic they are
they so this is the situation this is
what we are facing yeah is there any
future really for Christianity in the
Middle East I mean this has been going
on for a long time even if we look at
what's happened to the Coptic Christians
in Egypt who are pretty much gone
obviously all these countries all their
Jews are gone is there a real hope here
that this can be turned back or that a
safe haven could actually be that we get
the safe hasn't opened that they will be
there will be
a hope and future we want to build the
future in our by our own hand
the future cannot be about others to us
yeah so tell me a little bit about what
you're doing people say well you're the
commander in chief of the Assyrian army
what are you doing in Los Angeles in a
sharp suit what are you actually doing
here right now what are you trying to
accomplish
yeah actually we are after we
established our or dosha Assyrian army -
no [ __ ] mean the sacrifice of an Arabic
language in a Syrian element I should
know this from sure but it's the
language of the assuming people Arabic
it's the same they they call dynamic but
it's a Syrian is belonged at sea so when
we establish to establish after three
days four days after - Cupit our land in
Nineveh plain and we established in
field when the other peoples was fleeted
from the fight we pick up their arms and
go to fight Isis let me pause you there
so just a minute to be clear so when the
Iraqi army basically abandoned their
equipment which we gave them you guys
were able to take that equipment that
was in in June 2 2014
and - a Cupid Nineveh plain after one
month after that it was in
August 24 yeah so are you fighting Isis
there I mean there we know that they're
using American weapons sometimes too
because the Iraqi army man we see videos
of this all time Iraqi army abandon
stuff so are you guys both using the
same weapons that we gave to actually we
didn't get that no we we buy weapon from
from the market and we go to fight Isis
Isis took their weapon from the Iraqi
army and we buy the from the market we
buy the weapon but it was the simple
weapon it was not heavy weapons we don't
have heavy weapons to fight Isis just we
in that way Robin we want to give a
message to to the people to them at
least to our people art worst that
they're run away from the country or
emigrate from the country you know their
soul was broken afterward what they face
in the Nineveh plain so we want to build
that soul again that we can fight those
terrorists if we have the support from
the country we are as a Christian our
situation was the situation of the
Middle East in 1930 view back to their
to the history in 30s our situation a
Syrian situation was the situation first
situation in the Middle East so we want
to give that message to our people to
our neighbors from course
Arabs and others and to the coalition
force and to the countries that if they
support us we can go back and fight and
retook our land from and kick out the
from our land right so what is the
larger world the Christian community of
the world or what are they facilitating
arms to you guys you just don't hear
anything about this no no actually we we
don't ask about to to support us and we
ask to support our families you know the
fighter when he go to the to fight at
least he will think that his family is
living a good condition and a dignity
and they are not in need so what what we
what we call this is for this support
our families and this is what what we
say to the state of the Department of
State before people for months ago we
say to them that we are not here to came
to ask for money help our families
support us from with training and give
us weapons as a government and we can
fight Isis so God so in effect you guys
are asking for the same support that
we're giving the Kurds basically is that
in both way the situation Robin is in
two situation one part of that is a
humanitarian situation and the other
part is security situation security
situation is belong to how to to be the
area mineral plant secure so you have
political steps do you have a military
steps yeah they do an area are we
talking about and this is in Iraq well
it's long
maybe there'll be more than 5,000 square
kilometer and they have and it's rich
with power oil agriculture and
everything yeah you know so okay so you
got to train you you'd like if you
wanted the outside world to help the
help that you're looking for sort of
training help with the general security
we want the war to help us and to
support us and in the way that support
our our political demand and to help our
families support our families not let
them to in need we can go and fight yes
so is the problem really though that if
this is religious in nature not truly
about territory if ultimately whether
you had five hundred square kilometers
or sorry five thousand square kilometers
or whether you had five square
kilometers ultimately that's irrelevant
if this is really a religious conflict
right so how how does this get resolved
in a way even if even if the Assyrian
people want it resolved if the radical
Islamists don't want a resolved there's
almost no resolution here for that we
are we are asking there to help the
people if they don't feel they are
insecure or they trust they can build
the future no one can stay there
Reuben the situation is that area
belongs to the people and the majority
of that area belongs to the non-muslim
people so if and there are a decision
from the United State but it is just
talking about
something and there on the paper they
are not ranked after how to those
indigenous people they they face
genocide the first genocide like easy DS
and Christian people so how we can help
them to stay in there in their land so
yeah so the United States I assume you
have a bit of a complex relationship
with the United States because on one
hand as you said things weren't great
under Saddam on the other hand
post-saddam it was better for a little
while right was there was there like a
little window of a year or two where
there were some pre or elections where
it was actually safer to be ethnic
minority in Iraq Saddam same prosecute
our people in ethnic way they cannot say
you cannot say that you are i syrian you
can say you are Christian but Arab
Christian you cannot say that you are a
Syrian Christian so this is what's the
situation and under Saddam regime what
was the thinking there I mean I hear
everything is belong to our yeah the
same thing what do they face non Arab
people and then in the Iraq you know
most of the Arab countries are known on
our
it's the era by Arabization right they
were non-arab originally then
colonialism they became out yeah so this
is what was in Saddam
yeah but were things better for a little
when the Iraqi government when we were
still there and they were having
elections were things better as mine
already there for a little bit no for
the rise of Isis but nothing so even if
that both of them I told you about that
both of them are the same they same
thing but in a different way
yeah yeah it's the important thing that
the religion I think began from Saddam
in 1997 as I think yeah he became that
they called
religion campaign all family money in
Arabic it was 1997 so they began from
from that right so you guys so basically
you need weapons but you need awareness
and and some level of funds
I assume who are your greatest allies at
the moment actually the people who
believe in us and we have an
organization United Assyrian appeal that
help our families and we have different
friends like you Robin we have brandy he
he helped us in a different way so we
have people that help us and believe in
us yea I know we could talk about the
security situation forever and you could
we could go back forever to you and
every time you go back in the Middle
East you just go back to some other
conflicts and some other kind of as well
so let's then just let's talk about the
Assyrian people as a people if I if I
went back there with you when you're
here for about a week if I went there
with you what would it be like what
would the people be like the food's
they're eating how would it be different
than the normal the normal the the other
Iraqi culture that kind of thing give me
a sense of what the people are like
actually those people are now in need in
their land they have everything when
they are in their cities and then so now
they are living in the help of other
peoples so from one side that family
they have everything in their life and
just in one night they lose everything
in their life so if you came we will see
the same people that they are generous
they are people want to live in peace
but
the bus situation the political
situation they don't let us live in
peace
yeah and and the holidays they're
celebrating these there are it's the
denomination of Christianity but they're
celebrating all those Christian holidays
Easter
Christmas and we have monasteries that
built thousand years ago everything will
see that yes so so I guess also they
have different culture from from the
others
yeah so yeah what's the confidence more
openly more morality their culture will
belong to 7,000 years in the deep of the
history so they are more generous they
are creative people they have they live
in peace even if you ask now any anyone
from Iraq what do you think about the
question you say you will say is
good people and live in peace they don't
have any problems when area with anyone
so this is what what what it's different
from from the other people in Iraq yeah
what else can I do to help to help the
cause beyond get the information out
there I mean because that seems to me
you hear Syrian people think Syria you
know we just the name in itself is can
people just it's so much to tell you
Syria is became there from Assyrian
because Syria is the smaller of a Syrian
in our language so Syrian people is
different Syria is a state that al Assad
regime that rule now but a Syrian people
are belong to the Assyrian Empire and
their civilization a Syrian civilization
yeah so is that really and this has been
a through-line when I've talked to
people from other countries but
especially for Middle East but because
it's so hard to understand truly that
you know the Ottoman Empire ran
everything for hundreds of years and
then the British Empire took over for
whatever it was fifty years and then
since basically forty whatever that it's
been split up in so many different ways
there's just sort of it's just very hard
to get a hold on the good guys and the
bad guys and then you throw a religion
into it it's just it's just a big mess
and all you're trying to fight for is
your ability to survive is that is that
the end take actually we are fight for
for our people you imagine Ruben
everything happened since 300 years
before until now and the Middle East
they've been targeting our people our
Assyrian people from the Ottoman when
they fight the Persian Empire then they
the Ottoman they fighter then
in the World War one and World War two
and until now we are paying therefore
that we became their minorities we've
been the majority of the people there
yeah and it is just possible that the
Middle East will not tolerate minorities
anymore
right I mean as as depressing is that is
I hope that it not happen Robin but in
fact actually it's gone on if we don't
help their minorities to stay there yeah
there's there's so much more we can talk
about but I know we have some limited
time here but good luck on your your
venture here to get some awareness I
hope we did a little bit of that we're
gonna put some links down below so that
people will be able to find out more
about you and and what the Syrian army
is doing and I thank you guys for
watching and we'll do it again next week